[MUSIC PLAYING]
DANIELA CRUZ: Today
we'll be sharing
some insights we've uncovered
over the past two years.
From the marketing
side, I'll be sharing
some trends we've noticed
around how people are
using their digital assistants.
We've gathered these insights
from multiple research surveys,
in-home interviews,
and focus groups.
MEI LU: From the
UX side, I'm going
to share design recommendations
or implications based
on studies that we
conducted using diaries,
lab studies, or interviews.
Those recommendations are
based on common issues
that we have observed
in actions that
have been already deployed.
I'm a very bad person in
my team because I always
talk about the issues.
And I'm driving my team-- so
engineering or design teams--
crazy.
I hope to shed some light on
what high quality action means.
What are the key
components we need
to put in place to make an
action useful, trustworthy,
easy, or fun to use.
By the way, if any of you
do not know what action is,
it is basically the
experience you as a developer
create for Google Assistant.
On Google Assistant,
users can start
to interact with your experience
by simply saying, "hey,
Google."
DANIELA CRUZ: So
all this research
we've condensed into
five key insights
that range from looking at
general digital assistant
growth and how both consumers
and developers perceive
this new technology.
We'll also be looking at user
behavior trends in the home
and how to best design
for in-home usage.
We'll touch on some
trends we've noticed
regarding on-the-go usage
and how to best build
actions for mobile phones.
We'll look at how people are
using their digital assistants
across different
types of devices.
And last, we'll
talk about how users
would like to engage with
brands and third parties,
as well as sharing some
additional insights,
specifically regarding shopping.
So let's get started
with the first insight.
This space is big and
it's growing fast.
If we think back
to two years ago,
smart speakers were a novelty.
You would maybe go to
your friend's house
and if they had one, it
kind of felt like a toy.
You would spend
most of your time
asking it silly questions
like, "hey Google, tell me
the best dad joke."
However, since
then, smart speakers
have become a common term.
In the past year alone,
the Google Assistant
has become available in
over 1 billion devices
across 1,500 types of devices.
And this includes
everything from phones, TVs,
smart speakers, laptop,
pens, ear pods, clocks,
smart displays, microwaves,
anything you can think of.
It's also become available
in over 80 countries
and 30 languages.
So we're seeing
digital assistants
helping users across voice only
and voice in screens worldwide.
Let's just stop there and think
about that for one minute.
If we only keep in mind digital
assistant enabled smartphones
and no other of the devices
that I just mentioned,
these are still billions of
devices in people's pockets
that you could start
building for today.
Under developer
community, we're seeing
more than four times growth
and actions of Google projects.
And we're noticing actions
in Google categories
like games, home
automation, music,
actions for families
and education,
growing in popularity.
So with all of this
growth, we started
to wonder what people thought
about their digital assistants.
To get to the bottom of it,
we conducted some research
in the summer of last
year where we asked people
about the value of their
digital assistance.
In this particular
survey, we asked over
2,000 digital assistant
users in the US
how or if digital
assistants brought value
to their everyday lives.
And this is what
they had to say.
71% agree that digital
assistants allowed
them to more easily multitask.
70% agree that it makes
their life easier.
And 67% agree that it makes
their daily routines easier.
MEI LU: And on the
developer side,
Dani and I run our quarterly
survey with developers
worldwide.
That's 2,000 developers.
As this number shows,
developer sentiment
is pretty consistent
with that of consumers.
Around 70%, we
feel like they are
holding very positive outlook.
Developers feel
digital assistants
will drive innovation for both
software and the hardware.
And they will meet the
important user needs.
We have 21% said digital
assistant are just
a passing gimmick,
which means close to 80%
think digital
assistant will stay.
Overall, we are feeling that
this is an exciting space
to be in and that we
are seeing more to come.
In our interviews, we have asked
many developers this question--
why actions Google?
It's great to have
you on the platform.
But what brought you here?
This is a quote from
a gaming developer.
He was excited about creating
very natural and intuitive
interaction for
everyone, including
those otherwise might be
challenged to use technology.
Voice can be so intuitive,
available for everyone,
and it either enables hands
free and eye-free usage.
And it's also the cornerstone
for intelligent interaction.
This represents the primary
motive for many developers
we talk to.
But as we all have to agree,
voice-based interaction
can also be so challenging.
We asked many developers
this question--
what does a high quality
interaction mean to you?
And as one developer said,
high quality interaction
means it should be
trivial, effortless.
You don't need to
think about it.
You don't need to learn.
It just should be as fluid
as our daily conversation.
To me, these are the
two things that make
me excited about my daily job.
First of all, we are
hoping to make technology
available for everyone.
Secondly, it's challenging.
We have many problems to solve.
I really feel honored
to work with all of you
to try to solve this
problem together.
Then for the next four
insights, Dani and I
are going to talk about some
specifics about user trends
that we have observed and
discuss design implications.
DANIELA CRUZ: Great.
So let's start
with in-home usage.
Smart speakers have been used
in the home for a few years now.
So when we look
at in-home usage,
data shows that
it's becoming part
of people's everyday routines.
In a study we
conducted, we wanted
to understand how digital
assistants were being
embedded in people's lives.
We asked users to think
about their everyday routines
and think of the user
digital assistants in them.
If they answered yes,
we then asked them how.
What we found is that 89%
of respondents told us
they were leveraging
their digital assistants
during their daily routines
for multiple activities morning
through night.
And for some, it's even
becoming second nature.
We found that the three
most common routines
are happening in the home.
57% say they use their digital
assistants around the house
while relaxing.
So this could be anything like
playing a game or streaming
music after a long day's work.
43% say they use their digital
assistants when they're
getting ready in the morning.
So as people are multitasking,
making breakfast, getting
ready, they're also asking their
digital assistants for commute
information, for the
news, for the weather,
or maybe preordering
a cup of coffee
before they walk out the door.
And last 43% also say that they
use their digital assistant
when they're
planning their week.
Here we're seeing people
setting reminders,
adding calendar invites for
things later in the week.
They're researching
locations that they're
considering going to.
And sometimes even booking
restaurant reservations.
A quote like the
one you see here
is actually something
common we heard
when we were going
into the homes
of digital assistant
users and asking them
about their day-to-day.
They would say, my
digital assistant
is part of my daily routine.
I come down to the
kitchen, turn on my coffee,
and ask my digital
assistant for the weather.
MEI LU: These numbers,
percentage numbers,
are actually pretty
encouraging to me personally.
I was reading an article, a
recent paper about the adoption
of the internet.
The researchers said
it's the small things
that people use the internet
for on the everyday basis that
make it an integral
part of people's life.
Then they become indispensable.
We once invited 32
users to our lab
and observed how they use
different type of actions.
In the study, our
users were indeed
telling us they have been
using digital assistants
on the daily basis, often
times for small things,
just like weather.
Those small things are
entwined with many other things
they're doing at home.
Now, how should we design
the most engaging actions
for people's homes
that can be embedded
into people's daily routines?
After the first
encounter, it actually
needs to meet the
user expectations.
In our lab studies, we can see
user will very quickly abandon
action if they cannot easily
figure out how to use it.
The first step, oh,
how can I use this?
Then they also
carry expectations
for brands they are
already familiar with.
An example would be if it says
TED or CNN talk or action,
then they very much
expect to see videos
on the smart display.
If they are already using
your services on the web
or on mobile apps, at
this first encounter
they expect to see some
familiarity, some familiar
things that you get things done.
So if we order a
pizza or a car ride,
at that first moment,
encounter moment,
you do not want the user to
feel any kind of disappointment
or they feel they're
totally lost.
Then for next steps,
users will try to assess,
does this action provide
the right utility or values?
Is this something I want to use?
We find that users carry the
mental model of a signature
functionality--
signature functionality,
especially for brands
they are familiar with.
So for example, our research
colleagues in Google Maps teams
studied the user interaction
for Google Maps and ways
through assistant.
Those are similar apps.
We know they provide
similar functionalities.
But for Google Maps, the
user's signature functionality
is to ask for directions.
Then switched away, it becomes
to report accident via voice.
So I know many of you
probably focus on voice only.
You're creating brand new
experience on this platform.
Then signature
functionality is something
that will get a user excited.
That's something they
want to talk about.
Or it will have
captured attention
from maybe on social media
or from the product emails
they have received.
Some experiences are designed
across multiple devices.
Users can start from smart
speakers, for example,
then continue onto
mobile phones.
But for signature
functionality, do not do that.
Breaking it across multiple
devices will break the flow
and violate user trust.
Users definitely then
compare what they have--
compare action to what
they have on other devices,
especially on the mobile app.
They appreciate the actions
that provide convenience
beyond those solutions.
At this stage, we
see really they
are attracted to
quick solutions that
allow them to get things done,
especially when hands free.
So for this example, this user
has lived in different states
and he wants to keep
up with what's going on
in all those different places.
Then the radio action
allows him really
to easily get to those
stations just by saying
the name of the stations.
Overall, we need to
create aha moments.
And the users see it,
oh, that's interesting.
And then I want
to give it a try.
And they immediately
say, oh, this
is better than what I
have on other devices.
Navigation-- navigation
with voice only
or now with a combination
of the voice and the visuals
are still very new.
It's very common
for users to find
it hard to talk to
digital assistants.
Oftentimes, it users a brand
[INAUDIBLE] very common
for usability studies.
[INAUDIBLE] a brand [INAUDIBLE].
Oh, I just don't know
the right term to use.
But as this is one
more savvy user said,
technology actually [INAUDIBLE]
how to communicate better
with users.
For one example, in
an action we tested,
the action asked for
input for income.
And then the user would jokingly
say, income in millions.
I have make millions.
But then they actually
want to be able to take it.
The user reaction was
how am I supposed to know
you have these hidden rules?
In another example, a user
was to keep asking the action,
can you do this?
The action was very apologetic.
Sorry I cannot do this.
Then can you do this?
Sorry, I cannot do this.
Can you do this?
No, cannot do this.
So it becomes a guess and
a check kind of sequences.
At no point it actually
provide something, oh, I
can do this for you.
So better design would be the
action can be more intelligent
and maybe provide some
prediction, when app is done--
the question user asked.
And the offer, hey, I
can do this for you.
Whatever happens, please
kind of remember users
often time do not
know what's going on.
Is it because I did not
say the right thing?
Or is it because the device
or assistant does not
recognize me correctly?
Or it's just because the
functionality is not available?
So provide the right area
information that can guide them
through next steps or help
them to recover from error
is actually very important.
Once a user using
different actions,
I was just fascinated by
how many different ways
users can say to express
the same in [INAUDIBLE]..
A lot of work is
facing us to make
our language models, [INAUDIBLE]
models more flexible.
I have said this many times
to my teams, internal teams
at Google.
We need to improve
language recognition.
intent recognition.
We need to recognize
an entity better.
Or we need to recognize all
the problem names better.
And obviously, users
do not like to get
stuck at any step in the flows.
In one example, the
action was offered--
given list of options.
I can do this,
this, this for you.
What do you want?
The user said nothing.
And then the action said,
again, I can do this repeat.
I can do this,
this, this for you.
The user said, I
already said nothing.
So what action should
do at that step?
As you all may
know, users do not
like tree navigation structure.
They want to easily
go back or forward,
go back to the very beginning
to start over again,
or at any point they want
to start new conversations.
So again, think
about what Dennis
said about daily routines.
During those times,
users are either busy,
they are multitasking,
or they just
want to enjoy the time
with their families.
It is important from
beginning your action can
catch the attention, and then
throughout the conversation
maintain that attention.
So users have little patience
to learn at the beginning.
And the [INAUDIBLE]
voice, they actually
have very little patience
to try to make it work.
DANIELA CRUZ: But in their
home is not the only places
where we're seeing
behavior change.
As we said earlier, we saw the
popularity of smart speakers.
We noticed the
emergence of routines.
And now we're noticing
a new trend, which
is on-the-go on mobile phones.
We wanted to understand
how and where people
were using their digital
assistants on the phone.
So we ran a survey
and we saw that 76%
of smartphone digital
assistant use cases
are outside of the home.
And when we asked
people where you're
using your digital assistant,
we heard everything from, well,
I'm out and about
walking, running errands,
while I'm at work, or
even when I'm working out.
But probably the most
interesting part of this
is that out of these 76%,
54% of these are in the car,
because when you're driving
or stuck in traffic,
it's really convenient
to have a hands-free way
to access your phone.
While talking to people who
rely on their digital assistants
on the phone, we even
heard quotes like this one.
"I love how mobile it is.
My digital assistant
goes with me
everywhere-- at the beach, in an
elevator, walking, and so on."
But with people using
their digital assistants
on the phone, we have started
to hear both from developers as
well as from end users
desires to connect
between their apps
and their assistants,
since they both do
live on the phone.
So let's take a deeper
look into this need.
MEI LU: Yeah.
Recently we conduct
a study about how
apps and the digital
assistant should interact.
In the diary study,
we asked users
to spend four days to
document what they're
doing with their phones'
apps, and what kind of path
they want to complete.
Then afterwards, at
another four days,
we ask them to
document the moment
they wish digital assistant
could help you better
using those apps.
So on this chart
on the left side,
you can see users are using
their mobile apps to perform
a wide range of tasks.
Then on the right side, those
are digital assistant wishes.
And we call them wishes.
And now they're not
available, but can you
imagine how digital
assistant can help you
to better interact
with your apps.
And then we can see that
those wishes are widely
spread across all different
verticals of experiences.
This data shows that users
want the digital system
to help them with all
aspects of their daily tasks
on their phone.
Their main areas are--
top areas are-- money or
financial management, then
shopping and entertainment.
We put those digital
assistant wishes or use cases
into different categories.
And close to 70%
were about getting
things done very quickly
via the apps, mobile apps.
So about 30% about
voice commands,
users want to tell app
via voice to do something.
For example, be OK,
Google, start my run.
OK, Google, send this
picture to Instagram,
or share this
article with my wife.
Then 25% about queries.
Queries are just about getting
the information from the app
without picking up the phone
and then launch the app.
So it would be hey, what's my
balance in my credit card bill?
And how much charge I
have left in my Tesla car?
And then there's also a desire
for perform quick transactions,
for example, that just order
my coffee, order my usual,
and pay my bills.
So there's some financial
related quick transaction,
or using voice, get
a sequence of steps
done to maybe order my pizza.
I want to tell the system
what type of pizzas I want.
Further, users
also want a system
to actively work with them and
bring actions or information
to them without them
actually asking for it.
So proactive assistant means
that the assistant notice
the context the user's
in and then proactively
offer suggestions or help.
An example would be in a car.
Every day you do
similar things in a car.
You have time
during the commute.
So maybe notice that
you are in the car.
And then it will launch
your navigation map
and tell you how
much time it would
take for you to get to work
and launch your podcast
or music or audio books.
So a sequence of events
can happen together
by the assistant.
And all you reveal in the store,
shopping, the assistant-- the
want assistant or bring
up the shopping assistant
app so they can immediately
see their shopping list.
Smart compile means that they
want the assistant to work
across maybe multiple apps.
And they're all
working within the app
to pull information,
summarize it, and then bring
meaningful insight to them.
Example would be shopping.
I'm interested in this
design, design [INAUDIBLE]..
Can you look across
multiple shopping apps
and then offer me
the best price?
So implications for design
for the [INAUDIBLE] usage,
similar to home settings,
users are looking
for very fast solutions.
Or they simply
want to save time.
Or for shopping-related cases,
they want to save money.
So with either app
actions we just announced
that we are at the keynotes
or conversation actions
many of you have
already worked on,
you can allow users
to use the voice
to complete important
tasks on the goal,
or allow them to
quickly get information,
either from the app
or from other sources.
As this one user said,
it is very useful
to get status information from
app without taking out my phone
and then take several
steps to get out the phone
and then find the app.
We can think deeply on where we
can reduce the apps for users
for interaction flaws.
Users have told us
they actually want
to help not necessarily with
the apps they frequently use.
They hope it can happen
with apps they do not
use very frequently.
And they forgot
where the app is.
So you can help me define that
app, or with the functionality
that is now used all the time.
Then they forget where within
your app where that is.
And then using voice, I
actually can find it easily.
Respect the user's
effort means simply
do not waste the user's time.
We have seen that some
actions ask the users
for many steps of inputs.
Where's your address?
Where's your zip code?
What type of things
you want to order?
And then at the end--
sorry, I cannot do anything
because you have not linked
an account yet.
So users are usually
very mad at this moment.
They felt they had
been led to a dead end.
And we could see at those kind
of moments, they will give up.
They will bend the action.
So this just--
I will not try again.
It should minimize
request for inputs,
maybe as we become more
intelligent on the action side,
on the assistance side.
We should try to
source information
as much as possible
without asking users.
And employees, the
more questions you ask,
the more likely
they're going to drop.
By all means, avoid
asking same kind
of information, same employers,
at the same conversation
session.
We have seen that.
You just asked these
questions, exact same question.
I haven't even dropped off.
You ask again.
DANIELA CRUZ: So we've
seen both in the home
and on the go usage trends.
But we know that people don't
just stay to one or the other.
They occupy both spaces.
So for our fourth
insight, we've also
found that digital
assistants don't just live
in an isolated space or device.
What does this mean?
If you think of an app you
by default think of a phone,
because that's where they live.
Or if you think of a TV, you'll
think of your living room.
But when we think of
digital assistants,
you can really access them
across all types of devices
and trigger them anywhere.
And with this, of course,
comes a new set of challenge.
In our aim with our
team to understand
how we can make the product
better as people are going
from one device to the next,
we took a look at the devices
that people were using
when they were triggering
their digital assistants and a
little bit of what they expect
when they go between them.
We first asked users
what devices they already
owned that had built-in voice
activated digital assistants.
And after, we asked them which
ones they were actively using.
What we found is that
more than one third
of digital assistant
users are reaching out
to talk to their
digital assistants
on tablets and laptops.
And almost one third
are doing it on TVs.
Now, this to us was
really interesting.
We had almost assumed that
if you were on a laptop
and you had a question, you
would just open up a new tab
and ask for it there, as
that would make sense.
But what we saw instead
was something like this.
If I'm working from home,
instead of typing, "what's
another word for a kimono?"
I'll just ask my
digital assistant.
It's slightly faster than
opening up a new browser.
So they're going
as far as talking
to their digital
assistant, because it
feels more convenient to
them, despite already being
on a device that we would think
they would continue their usage
pattern.
So what we're
seeing is that we're
seeing a break in their
expected behaviors.
We also wanted to
know how people
are going between
devices and found
that 57% of dual device users--
so these are users
that are accessing
their digital assistants across
different types of devices--
made requests on one
device that they then
expected to pick up on another.
So what does this look like?
An example here would be music.
If you are on the go
and you're on your phone
and ask your digital assistant
to start playing music,
they would then get home
and ask their smart speaker
to continue playing music
and expect them to pick up
exactly where they left off.
Another one would be directions.
If you're already at
the home and you're
talking to your smart speaker,
telling it how long will it
take me to get to work?
They expect that as they
walk out their door,
they're going to get the
directions and traffic
information on their phone.
We've heard over and over
again that these dual device
users are expecting
a seamless flow
from one device to the other.
MEI LU: So design across
multiple products.
Assistant is a place
in the user's mind
that they can interact
with apps or webs.
Here are some examples
that users have told us
or without us prompting
them with any ideas.
So for example now,
for recipe action,
they want to be able
to search on the web
and then add favorite
to the action.
And then when
they're cooking, it's
ready on their smartest place.
Or when the assistant
asked in this example,
do you want me to send
this recipe to your phone?
The user said, yes, sure.
How about next steps?
Can you add ingredients
to my shopping list?
And users expect or they
appreciate the intelligence
if an action can recognize
the user as an individual
and adapt the
experience over time.
We heard a lot of a desire
to remember users have said,
to remember user's preferences.
Now we are working on those.
And [INAUDIBLE].
A simple adaptation is
about a welcome message
and the many actions
provide a introduction,
a welcome to my action.
But they keep playing
that every time.
So the message
becomes very old--
quickly become old
after one or two times.
So we can think about how we
recognize that this is a--
you haven't tried
my actions before.
Then they also want to be
able to interrupt maybe
some sessions, then switch
out and then go back.
And the example would
be I am cooking.
I'm using recipes.
And now I'm switching out to
use the music and come back.
So resumption is very important.
DANIELA CRUZ: Now, the last
insight we wanted to share
was a specific use case to
put all of this into context.
And it's probably one of
the more surprising findings
that we came across
during our research.
And it's that users
are leveraging
their digital
assistance when shopping
and that they want
to see you there.
So knowing that people were
using digital assistants
in many different
parts of their lives,
we set out to understand how
they were using it specifically
to shopping.
And this includes all
types of shopping,
so not necessarily just
making the transaction,
but everything along the
path to purchase funnel.
What we found is that over
one third of assistant users
are leveraging
their digital assets
and for at least one
shopping-related activity.
Now, it's not necessarily
the transaction,
but it is everything from
researching products, creating
shopping lists, searching
for local information,
managing orders and more.
And when we see where
they are doing it,
we're seeing people doing
these types of activities
with their digital assistants
across different places
like in the house, in
the car, on the go,
while at work, but
more interestingly,
when they're inside a store.
So to understand
this further, we
ask users how they would like
to engage with third parties
and businesses on
their assistant.
And what we found is the above.
And I'm not going
to read all of them.
But I'll just point out the
ones that are more interesting.
So 45% told us they would like
to find business information.
This is anything from knowing
store hours to locations.
33% told us that they want
to receive personalized
information as your used
to their digital assistants
already catering precise
information to them.
So it's going to be anything
from deals, promotions, or even
events that may be relevant.
And 30% told us that they want
to access customer service
and support as this
platform already
starts [INAUDIBLE] for that
conversational interface.
To put this in perspective,
this is a quote
we heard from one
of our users when
we were asking them
about how they use
their assistants for shopping.
And they said, I was so crazy
busy one night last summer.
I had a craving at 10:00 PM
for strawberry shortcake.
I know this restaurant
closes at 11:00 PM,
so I asked my digital assistant
to get me strawberry shortcake
and it showed up
45 minutes later.
It was that easy.
MEI LU: Yeah, this is
a quote from a user who
have a child retail
brand which offers
simple services
like finding a deal
or finding my store locations.
And then this is the end to end,
he said that, wow, this is--
I'm liking the brand
better because it
offers simple ways for me to
make a connection with them.
So how we design for the brand?
We love your brands,
and so do end users.
Uses make an association
with a brand in many ways.
It can be your logo.
Can be your signature sound,
slogan, and the special color
schemes, your unique
buttons you have created,
and the special ways
you get things done.
So a visual display provides
opportunities for you
to represent your brand in
more rich and prominent ways.
Users also want to
see visual content
on the smart displays, including
images, videos, animations.
A lack of a visual
content now I think
it is regarded as
lack of effort.
So it will somehow breach user
trust and their perceptions
of your brand.
Further, they expect action
through leverage of display
to provide suggestions,
guidance on what you offer
and how you can use the actions.
Fun and personality only work
when the rest has been good.
So that means the action
provide useful functionality
and also provide
smooth navigation.
So as one user said
about a brand he liked,
he liked the functionality.
And then it also
offers some fun facts.
I like the fun facts
towards the end.
But the second quote
is about the action
that did not provide
signature functionality,
uses the word
disappointing, and then
there is the, why am I going
to interest in fun facts.
So yeah, it is important to
work on the functionality
and the navigation first, and
then fun and the personality
will amplify the impact.
Do not over-talk and do
not waste users time.
And they like organic voices,
high quality organic voices,
or interesting accents that
compliment your services, just
like Italian accents
for a pizza action.
DANIELA CRUZ: Now I know
you've heard a lot from us
today, but if you leave
here with just one thing,
we went out to the users, and
we asked them point-blank--
do you want to engage with
brands and third parties
on digital assistants?
And 80% of users
said that they would.
MEI LU: In our studies we also
asked the user this question--
if there is a third
party sub action and then
the Google equivalent assistant,
which version would you prefer?
Users actually told us
they prefer third parties
because you put more
skin in the game.
So as key takeaways,
identify and enable
your signature functionality.
Ask of yourself what's
that one thing that's
most for your users?
And then enable that signature
functionality very well.
Do not break them across
different devices.
And then actions,
apps, and the webs
are all part of a
people's journey
for getting things done.
Continuous experiences
or integrated experiences
across all different
products will divide users.
Design and test,
design and test,
maybe design the test
multiple times for efficient
and guide the interaction flows.
Do not let users drop off
during the conversations.
And with the assistant
and with visual displays
with the personalities,
now you have new ways
to build your brand
or extend your brand.
Maybe you can make them
friendly, funny, quirky,
sarcastic, or weird.
I was from Portland, Oregon and
we love being weird over there.
So as a conclusion, I want
to emphasize two words--
small and trivial.
We can start with small things
people do on a day-to-day basis
and make your action
integrated into daily routines.
Then trivial, your action needs
to be trivial and effortless.
DANIELA CRUZ: Awesome.
So thank you guys all so much
for coming by and listening
to our talk.
We'll be hanging out later
at the Assistant sandbox.
I think it's open
for a few more hours
if you want to
stop by and say hi.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Thank you.